let's take some phone calls the number
is 6 1 7 8 30 for 750 we have the first
caller caller please identify yourself
where are you calling from and what
what's on your mind today oh um I'm from
sort of the deep south area and all this
stuff where we got kinda crazy things
going on but I wanted to note that was
your show yeah compared to most of the
shows i see on youtube and otherwise is
not polarized i was wanting on at all
right whatever you mean that the
audience is not polarized no i mean in
general like how you report because it
seemed to me that was a lot of shows and
in general see people kind of seemed
like they feel the need to be polarized
but extremely couldn't last extremely
the right you know for example you
talked about safe spaces in touch yeah
and you did it you know without me like
gosh dang as JW's at the same time you
were like well everyone just be able to
completely shut themselves off in the
world you know I see what you're saying
yeah right right one will listen no I
mean and what's interesting about what
you're saying is I feel like the show
has never been more more polarized in
the sense of I feel like I've never been
more liberal and I'm not afraid of of
saying that I think what you're sort of
pointing out is I don't always jump on
what's the popular left bandwagon if I
believe it doesn't represent liberal
principles like the safe space type of
thing I mean is that I don't wanna with
peace and love I'm standing to you the
possibility that i'm sort of rephrasing
what you're saying yeah you definitely
are like more or less meaning that you
not really need to like just go with
that so to speak team like oh
everything's acceptable as long as it
came from the side that kind of thing uh
I don't think we've ever had a better
caller uh what what is your name by the
way I didn't catch it my name is Sofia
Cynthia okay Cynthia from the deep south
yeah I'm sorry say it once more
I'm sorry Sofia Sofia okay Sofia from
the deep south uh thank you so much for
the call I appreciate your analysis and
uh I hope more people sort of see that
that this is an opinion show but that it
is not just checking the boxes of what's
a fad right now among the left thank you
so much for the call I've talked about
how people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is zip car which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zipcard each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between 1100 and 1,600
pounds per year for our audience zipcar
is offering $25 a free driving credit if
you sign up at joined zipcar dot-com
slash david support our show reduce your
carbon emissions and you're spending on
cars sign up at join zipcar dot-com
slash david